merci la politique française au parti
socialiste le nouveau premier secrétaire
henri emmanuelli s'installe dans ses
meubles il a présidé aujourd'hui son
premier bureau national un congrès du
parti socialiste devrait se tenir fin
octobre reportage d'hélène chenu
le tout nouveau premier secrétaire
cherche encore ses marques alors
qu'aujourd'hui c'est son examen de
passage devant le bureau national du
parti tous sont là assis autour de lui
ceux qui ont fait son élection sans
oublier les autres ceux qui n'ont pas
voté pour lui et l'on parle de la suite
de l'organisation d'un congrès et des
courants ces sondes par les courants et
trouvons l'équipe qui peut permettre de
faire redémarrer le parti social dans le
sorte d'intervalle ou d'intérim le mieux
à mon avis c'est qu'en effet tout le
monde de collaboration
et tout sera remis en cause en octobre
il leur a donc un congrès et un vote des
militants
l'occasion pour henri emmanuelli de
légitimer son élection et de compter
combien sont ses amis et combien sont
les autres les rocardiens par exemple je
souhaite ensuite qu'à l'issue de ce
congrès si possible il existe dans le
parti socialiste une majorité et une
minorité
afin que ce parti retrouve une
respiration démocratique un
fonctionnement normal quant à la
nouvelle équipe ait les resserrer autour
du premier secrétaire tous les courants
ils sont représentés on y trouve même un
rocardien tout cela pour définir une
nouvelle ligne en bref une traduction
politique du virage à gauche souhaité
par henri emmanuelli